Douglas McGregor is a retired US Army
curl author the fantastic book margin of
victory frequent guests in the show he
joins us tonight some thanks so much for
coming on sure so what would be the
reason to stay in Iraq at this point I
can't think of any to be perfectly blunt
with you i none that are any good there
are people who sympathize with those
Arabs in Iraq who would like us to stay
as some sort of counterweight to Iran
but frankly we have no vital strategic
interest that compels us to be there the
president is very lucky these missiles
as you pointed out were targeted in
advance and we were informed in advance
of where they were going to land so we
were able to evacuate soldiers sailors
airmen and Marines and have no
casualties the president made a right
decision not to respond now he needs to
live up to the promises that he made to
the American people and pull us out of
both Syria and Iraq that war is over we
lost it Iran is a winner for the moment
but it won't be a winner for very long
because Iran has to compete with the
Turks and the Sydney Islamists for
control of Iraq so our interests do not
involve Iraq and Syria our interest be
begin along a line that runs across the
top of Israel Jordan Saudi Arabia around
Kuwait and down to the middle of the
Persian Gulf yep that's where our
interests have been to the gulf of
course so you're saying that if we want
to impede the growth of Iran's influence
in the region
hand them Iraq and wish them luck in the
same way that the the Soviets invading
Afghanistan precipitated the end of the
Soviet empire is that what you're saying
mr. Ayer Dewan and Turkey has made it
very clear that he covets northern Iraq
he would like to control all of Syria he
is now sending Sunni Islamist fighters
and Turkish troops into Libya and
Tunisia
he is the new problem for us not Iran
Iran really is on the ropes
it's population is sick to death of the
wars that have been fought in Iraq and
Syria by proxy forces and by Iranians
and the Kurds force they've taken
thousands of casualties
mr. Soleimani was popular with many
but very unpopular with others
especially the people that lost sons
fighting in those countries yes let's
get out leave it alone let the people
there sort it out and they will Iran's
not gonna be popular for very long in
Iraq is there any hope that that happens
well the president can do it he has a
wonderful opportunity now he's a new
point of departure he can take the clean
sheet and and put it on the table and he
can sit with the Iranians and say look
what are your interests tell us we'll
tell you what ours are and he can draw
that line that I mentioned that can
become the Trump line and that's how
great powers sort things out but there's
no support in this country to stay in
Iraq and Syria there is no support in
the United States for a war over there
he knows that so we have to two groups
of people that know something the
leadership in Tehran knows it doesn't
want a war with us we know we don't want
a war with them what a wonderful
opportunity to sit down and sort it out
the only impediment is permanent
Washington yes that's all well thank you
so much for that